how did your short film diet go viral
i wish i knew i'm just kidding um
i think that with diet first of all
we've we
we have isolated a few things that work
well for us on youtube and that is a
really interesting thumbnail
and you know you just learn that again
by doing so we had
uh bedhead like i already described we
had a conversation with tv this big
channel they were interested in
promoting bedhead on their channel
and they asked for some assets from us
and when they asked for the thumbnail
they wanted us to brighten it and show
the monster in a certain way
and i mean their massive channel and so
once we learned that we were like well
that must be what's working for them
let's do that for us and i want to say
that diet was the very first time that
we did that for ourselves we
applied that little bit of like oh
what's ever working for them let's do it
for us
um so we have the monster as the
thumbnail and it's like decently lit so
you can really see what's going on there
and then i think the title also helps
because you know
diet it doesn't when something goes
viral it doesn't mean that like the
subject matter itself
is what makes it viral sometimes you can
go viral just from the thumbnail and the
title
because you know someone can't know that
they liked it until they watch it so
you get the watch and you go viral
through people just being enticed enough
to watch
and so i think diet is enough of a you
know it's a short word they get it
they're like okay i know what diet is
like and dye
is in there and interesting so i think
that was a good hook to get people
interested and then after that you know
we start the the whole short is
about misdirecting the horror tropes so
and and by the way i have to shout out
aaron for this he came out came up with
diet on a hike
he i was a few paces back he shouted the
idea back to me and i was like
i love it we have to make it and i mean
that was a hundred that's 100 his flavor
his style and i just i love the short so
much
and it's also been him who's he's done
the groundwork of figuring out what
works on youtube
he was the one who was like oh brighter
thumbnails work okay showing the monster
like in this sort of composition works
and and he was going in hand-holding the
channel for the first few shorts
where he was like okay this isn't really
this isn't hitting like this doesn't
seem like this is getting a lot of views
within the first few hours let me change
out the thumbnail and so he was doing
that and really like
micro adjusting to a point where all of
a sudden our channel started
growing like like moving and grooving
with a beat you know and
and that was really fun and i was happy
to see him do it too because i'm kind of
the one with the marketing background
and here he is taking this and running
with it and i was
so happy because you know he's learning
his own uh levels of marketing and it
was really helpful it was super helpful
and it helps us to this day and
i think that really helped us go you
know quietly like viral for for
diet and when did you actually post it
i want to say so we thought of diet for
aaron's birthday
that was end of may so it must have been
um
around june i want to say like mid-june
that's when you posted it
yeah yeah and so it has over 2.4 million
i think so something like that even i'm
like that's how many it has
delightful and my face is the thumbnail
but like all just
like gross and disfigured as a monster
so like two and a half or so million
people have just been seeing like like
most people have seen my face
they don't know it but i don't i hardly
know it i'm like oh that is me isn't it
and so when you would you like go to bed
and then see all these comments
overnight like wake up to like
love it and you know wow that's so cool
oh i didn't think the ending was gonna
be like that and be like whoa what's
happening here
yeah yeah and a bit like that was really
really cool when that
started happening i worry
that the internet is a scary place and i
was kind of a little too
like nervous i didn't want people to be
mean in the comments so i didn't read
the comments that much
and diet is polarizing you know it's
kind of meant to be more of a comedy
horror
but you know we kind of market it as
just a horror and then therefore
that's led to a few dislikes and a few
mean comments but you just roll with it
aaron reads all the comments and he
he'll show them to me and i'm like
whoa whoa that's cool but i also i kind
of feel like i was just
really really lucky because i didn't i
don't know i just like the comments are
rolling in the views are rolling in and
you're just kind of like
cool let's do another one and you never
we never took a break we never took a
break from that we were like let's just
keep going keep going keep going
and it was almost like we now had this
new expectation all right our next one
has to get just as many views and as
many comments and
um you know i feel really really lucky
that that's happening although it has
slowed down lately but i think the
christmas season is kind of just
you know that's the style right yeah i
didn't take it it was as it was mean
i'm surprised people you said people i
know you said people were mean with the
comments but oh yeah there were some
things that people were offended by or
no
oh not exactly offended i think they
don't like uh that
that it's not strictly horror you know
because we're it's really comedy we're
we're trying to
make fun of all the comedy trolls or i'm
sorry the horror tropes through comedy
and so
uh you know obviously in the short you
know and then anyone can watch this it's
a very short short
uh you open with the character who's
like butchering these poor carrots and
he's cutting them totally the wrong way
and you just see all
like you think for sure he's gonna slice
off his finger
then he reaches into the garbage
disposal all these things that we've
seen in
classic horror films which we love um
and he keeps like just
narrowly escaping death and i won't give
away the fine of the finale of the short
because i really love the button on it
um but yeah that i think that's kind of
like some people were like how dare you
put something comedic in this and i'm
like
enjoy it skip to the next short it's all
good
did anyone offer to buy the content
no they never did okay is that a
i know in the thing i don't know but
maybe just because now
you know people's youtube channels are
thriving and things but i feel like in
the past maybe
sometimes they would want to buy content
so i'm just wondering if anyone had
asked since it's
been so successful oh sure i mean i
could see it happening maybe in the
future at some point
i still think that the channel is so in
its infancy you know if you think about
us only really taking it seriously from
like
diet onward which would be six months
i could see that happening but you know
if anyone's thinking about it diet's
kind of our cash cow on the channel so
it's going to have to be a
an attractive offer right and has anyone
written to you and asked how did you do
it i want to do this
yes yeah those are the best emails that
we get when and and
because of that we actually always make
making up videos for every short
which i love thank you i love is like a
little time capsule even for us just to
remember like all the little behind the
scenes things that we were doing when
filming
um but we are completely like we really
want anything we know
we're happy to share it and we're like
happy to see other people feel inspired
and
learn how how it is that we did it
little tricks of the trade i mean
i think that essentially every indie
filmmaker looks up to the david f
sandberg
type of model and he did that you know i
remember watching his making of for
uh i don't know i think it might have
been lights out or maybe attic panic
but he's talking about how he uses this
little ikea trashcan for the like
and you're just thinking like yes
they're look at this hat like i love
this hack i love that this this helpful
nature
and it helps break down the barriers of
people thinking you need to have all
this money and all of this stuff and
no we can use kind of things around the
house and sometimes aaron uses
toilet paper or a sock to diffuse light
you know to help the light be a little
we he does all types of things and we
try and share them with people because
we're
paying it forward like you know we
learned a lot we grew let's try and help
you know people who are maybe a few
paces behind us
what did you learn from diet going viral
that can
help other filmmakers well i would
certainly say um
the thumbnail the thumbnail is kind of
king if you choose to do
you know something like a monster
because obviously we're in horror so
that's the advice i can give
you will get a little bit of feedback in
the comments where people say i wish you
didn't show the monster
but you probably wouldn't have clicked
if you didn't see that creepy monster in
the thumbnail and we need you to click
to watch the short and then hopefully
get to know our channel and then watch
more
um so that would be some big advice it's
like really focus on
your thumbnail um try your best to do
some sort of commitment to the channel
you know you don't have to be posting as
often as us
at all like you know this is what we do
now for a living so if you can only even
do
one some piece of content per month or
as long as you're just like staying
active on your channel in some capacity
i think that the algorithm really likes
that it likes to it doesn't have to be
in a regimented schedule like i said but
just
stay active on the channel you can even
be commenting on other channels from
your account doing community posts if
you if you have that feature
um but you can definitely be staying
active on the channel and activity
is what i i believe that the channel
wants to see or the
the platform itself youtube itself it
wants to
raise people who are using it and using
it to like what it was
what its purpose is to the top and that
will help you be found in searchability
um try your best not to to convolute
your title like if you can ever think of
something that's just going to be really
really
tight and short that way it doesn't get
cut off you know because if people see
recommended videos on the right side of
their screen
they might not see everything that
you're writing so just try your best to
keep that really tight
um and then yeah like again with the
thumbnail try and make it bright because
write it brighter you know just don't do
something that's full pitch black if you
can
um because you want someone to kind of
be enticed to click through
and yeah other than that you know make
the channel your channel a welcoming
environment you know put some nice cover
up there you know all the kind of
bells and whistles that someone does
once they start taking their channel
more seriously
and then yeah don't be don't be afraid
to kind of
pitch your creation to blogs and other
channels you know you could there are
plenty of reaction video creators
and there are big ones huge massive
titan of cr
reaction videos corey kenshin has
reacted to us like three or four times
we got massive a massive influx of
subscribers because he
liked our short film watched it and then
told his like seven million
or i think it's eight million now
subscribers social house films makes
fantastic shorts go
check them out and we got like this
massive influx like i think it was like
15 000 subs in a day it was like whoa it
was
just a really exciting day um so that
would be my advice is just go ahead and
like promote your work do the best you
can to promote your work
when you're putting uploading your work
make sure it's bright
clear crisp and and really do just try
try to make a tight solid quality
project because that's what's
people will come back they will
absolutely come back did you take any
classes in
seo keywords search
not classes per se but my first job out
of college was uh
was working at a startup for tech
accessories and
and they i mean they're great like a
startup you're
you're thrown right into it and you have
to kind of figure it out um of course
there are other people there that know a
little bit more than you and they'll
teach you
but it was a lot of learning by doing at
that company you know we we're trying to
sell a product you know i knew
i was working closely with the whole
team and how can we just really
you want success for the whole team so i
was learning a lot at that time
and i used those skills to try and help
help us today but
personally i kind of feel like that's
always in flux and so
i i don't even know that i would tell
someone you have to go to school for
that
i would say like do your best now with
what you have and just
constantly be aware of lessons that you
can tuck away like the lesson i gave
about the crypt tv
i'm sorry tv comments about our
thumbnail we could have easily
just sent it to them and not realized
that that was a little nugget of
a tidbit for us instead we were like oh
that worked for them
we're going to do that for us and and i
think that that's been really helpful
for us so just stay tuned to
lessons that you might be able to learn
as you go
just going back to what you talked about
with corey the youtuber the this
reaction yeah
youtuber um did he seek you out or did
you
see his channel and send your film to
him well so we
we received an email from him one day
asking for permission to react to it you
know because he
he him with having such a massive
channel he has to make sure there's
copyright clearances
and we didn't know who he was at the
time we got this fairly nice email from
this guy
corey and so we clicked through his
channel we're like
oh my gosh i can't believe this is gonna
happen and what we learned is that from
his
massive um group of followers they go on
twitter and they'll share
videos that they really like on and they
like at him on twitter and they say
please react to this it's such a good
short blah blah and that we didn't we
don't use twitter that often so we went
over to twitter and now we found like
pages and pages of people submitting it
to him and also just also sharing our
work in general he doesn't always pick
everything that's sent to him
he i think maybe randomly chooses or
maybe you know kind of has
i don't really know how he chooses but
we we have been lucky enough for him to
react a few times and i sent him a dm i
was like oh my god thank you so much i
was just over the moon i could have like
cried with happiness it was so fun
that's really cool wow so so even better
than him finding it his followers
recommended
yes which is like the ultimate
compliment yes exactly and then and then
he does the reaction video we get to
watch him reacting to our work
and then we go in the comments and say
like you know thank you so much and
people will respond to us on his video
saying we love you too social house
films like this was a great like it's
just this wonderful group of
friendliness and and people all enjoying
these short films and it's really really
fun it's like a community you know
you